i can't even get over how much talent
this person has it's simply unfair
please welcome to the bananamore stage
rachel
feinstein
thank you so much thank you for having
me here it's nice to be here in
front of this nana's sign i'm married to
a firefighter
uh i mean i think he's a fireman he
could just be a stripper with the
fireman costume but uh
the hard thing about being married to a
fireman is like you can't change his
mind about anything because the men at
the firehouse have
access to my husband's brain for like
half the week like he'll come home
with conspiracy theories he'll be like
vinnie said they legit
never went to the moon i'm like don't
believe anything vinnie says
especially after he says legit this is
my life now i just have to go to these
staten island dinner dances
with the other fire spouses and he'll
just deposit me somewhere
at some shrimp station one of the
vinnies just goes to me
you gotta come with me and my wife to
epcot and then he goes that's the real
japan sweetheart
that's japan with no irony whatsoever
he goes people think he gotta spend all
this dough
flying all the way to japan but it's a
scam
he referred to traveling the world as a
scam
and epcot as reality somehow because but
it's not true because it's all right
there
and we got to time [ __ ] in but it's
confusing for me because i like get
infuriated by them but then i'm actively
aroused by all of them
it's just a very confusing sensation and
it's hard right now to be with the first
responder because it's really hard to
argue when we're on the street and he's
in his uniform
because people just stop my husband and
they'll be like thank you for your
service
i'm like he's actually being kind of
right now and i'm in the middle of a
point
so it's weird and our families are
completely
opposite like my mom is like
aggressively liberal she loves
complaining about trump my mom will
blame
anything on trump she'll be like i
haven't slept a wink
since this jerk was in office
i'm like you had sleep apnea years
before trump
and also you can't why are you spelling
jerk it's not a bad word
and i don't know if anybody has a parent
like this but like
my mother over shares that's how we
connect in my family like every time i'm
alone with my mother
she'll just tell me something i never
wanted to know she'll have like one
mudslide who drinks mudslides anymore
no one in the world except karen
feinstein one slide with my mom
and just hits the fan she'll be like
fine there was a year when i did
consider leaving your father i'm like i
don't want to know that
she's like i called it my dark year i'm
like you
title years of your life she goes yes
that was my dark year that's the year
where i would part my hair
down the middle i'm like you don't know
darkness you teach low-impact aerobics
and his family is the opposite like they
don't discuss emotions at all
my husband will deny that he has
emotions
we were having an argument once and he
just like i come from over sharers just
like jewish overshares
he'll deny he has an emotional history
we were having an argument once and
i go i don't know if you've ever had an
issue with that we were discussing
something
and he goes i've never had any issues i
was like i don't think i've
ever even heard anyone declare that
you've never had an issue
he goes nah i never had any issues not
in childhood or after that
it was pretty much a straight shot for
me i'm like really because you just
punch the microwave
i'm not sure if you're aware of that and
he can't
compliment i don't know if anybody's
married to somebody like this he doesn't
know how
like on our wedding day i was walking
down the aisle and he's like bringing it
i'm like that's not gonna land that's
what you say to a running back
not your wife on a wedding day because
they did a good job with the makeup i'm
like you're not supposed to mention the
makeup
that's actually hurtful that's like
saying i like the active lie they
plasted on your face
we should tip her big for what she was
able to do
wow true genius that girl that's what
you say it awake
like they did a good job with the makeup
i thought marie looked very tasteful
in a dress we just come from a
completely opposite
yeah totally opposite families and my
parents like
they don't really watch what i do like
they just want to talk about world
suffering and his family wants to talk
about like what they got at costco
and every time i talk to my parents
about like if i try to explain to them
that i did something on tv it's
exhausting trying to tell them how to
find something i did
on zoom will like put me out for a month
i tried to explain to my mother that i
had a special on netflix
this is an actual conversation i had
with her she goes
we tried to view your netflix program
but it turned out it was a scam
i'm like how would the largest streaming
service ever personally scam you intend
she goes well we took all the steps to
watch the program
but we were scammed we went to mailboxes
etc and we mailed the dvd to them
i'm like what the what did netflix
receive at headquarters for my parents
you understand that my mom and dad like
masked up and
drove to mail some i don't know what was
it like a tape of my bot mitzvah
what happened i have no idea my mom
hates that joke she's always like take
that one out of your talent show skit
that's what she calls my stand up my
talent show skit
i had a baby this year and i was really
nervous to have a baby my worst fear
when i had a child not just because the
pandemic
i was i was like what if i don't connect
to her which i guess every
that's every mother's like worst fear i
was like what if i don't like feel
anything
and um because i'm an over sharer too
and i'm like i'll just start telling
people
i'll be at a barbecue and somebody would
be like oh that's a cute baby and i'll
be like isn't it weird that i don't love
her
so thank god i do love her which i guess
makes me a hero too
[Music]
you